after the hour of 6:00 and evening of
January 31 1985 and we're located in
offices Jason two offices occupied by
the Federal Bureau of Investigation in
San Antonio Texas for the purpose of
interviewing Gordon Joseph Rayner
under hypnosis in order to refresh his
memory of events that he may have
witnessed associated with an undercover
reverse operation in Miami Lakes Florida
on or about March 11 1981 in addition to
myself James W Kenney a special agent of
Federal Bureau of the investigation and
DEA Special Agent Rainer others present
this time our Gerardo Cesar Medina
senior inspector from Drug Enforcement
Administration headquarters in northland
DC and dr. Richard P Garver a clinical
psychologist and private practice in San
Antonio Texas do you understand why we
are here and what what the purpose of
the interview is yes I don't and you
understand that your participation has
to be voluntary it you cannot be coerced
or forced when you're ready to undergo
an interview such as yes I am going to
voluntarily do you have any objection
does videotaping these entire persons
not at all
do you have any objection to any of the
people that are present
five and present throughout the area now
if you do it anytime please let us know
okay obviously if you objected dr.
Garber will be selling figure problems
basically what we're going to do and
just will let dr. Garber will talk with
you and afterwards I'll ask you to
relate for us at a remember level a
conscious recollection of any events
associated with this particular
operation and that's the only thing that
is what happened in Miami Lakes Florida
in this operation of the 11th of March
1981 we don't care which he for
breakfast or anything else fine and then
if you agree will sign a consent form
and then we'll go into the broader
community sharing time of night at this
time I'd like to give just a little
background and dr. Garber he's a
certified and licensed clinical
psychologist from private practice in
San Antonio Texas he's involved with
treatment of several hundred patients
each month in the training of many
doctors in hippotherapy he's a diplomate
in the American Board a psychological
hypnosis with especially in clinical
hypnosis and serves as a special
consultant to the FBI he's here today
because we consider your welfare in this
interviewing fine do you have any
questions in the middle no not at all
now we've had just a moment to meet and
I need to tell you what we're here to do
in terms of how we're going to use
hypnosis it knows this is an altered
state of consciousness so in a way it's
an invasive procedure but the way it's
going to be used here
really is more relaxation and a focus
than anything else I want to give you
some information about hypnosis answer
any questions you have and then tell you
exactly how we're going to use it in the
interview some people think of hypnosis
as a sleep state it's really not the EEG
is different than sleep and actually
it's going to be in this situation more
like having a daydream you're going to
be aware of being relaxed and being here
be aware of things around you a person
who would be having hypnosis for surgery
would not we would ask them to
disassociate we would ask them to go
fishing or hunting or where they wanted
to go and we see that they get there and
that they wouldn't be here wouldn't
remember anything but obviously that
would be counter to what we're wanting
to do here this is to enhance memory and
hypnosis has as its center a focus now
the focus for the surgery patient is
kind of the same focus that you or I
would have if we listen to a boring
speaker it wouldn't be the speaker would
be away someplace we hope that this will
be the same kind of focus that a woman
would have when she's birthing a child
with hypnosis she doesn't want to be
away she wants to be a part of that
she's hypnotized to produce anesthesia
but she's very much involved here and
now if we were listening to a very
interesting charismatic speaker we would
be very much involved here and to the
exclusion of other things that's where
the focus will be it will be here part
of you mind focusing on our questions
and you will also
then be somewhere else we're asking you
to go back to a situation I call it a
memory walk just back visualize this
other place this other time where you
have certainly been and place yourself
there and then go with us forward from
there as though were happening now go
forward through that period of time as
you know we can do it slowly carefully
we can kind of stop the action and and
have you go only that far and then
answer some questions take it a little
further and so on
and it would as I understand it it will
be at a time that where you were
involved with the action so you will
have been there you simply be there
again and and tell us what you're doing
as you go through it again in your mind
and essentially that's that's it
the reason that we ask you is June will
in a moment to consciously go through it
first is to see what the difference is
between your conscious recollection
which is of course being here and the
present and trying to remember back as
to what happened as opposed to getting
relaxed and then going back there and
going forward as though we're happening
now and it seems to elicit far better
recall than it does to be here and
remember so basically that's that's why
we do that
comparison have you tell Mr Kenny
consciously what you remember and then
we do the hypnotic interview so that's
it in a nutshell I guess I need only to
know I might as well ask you now before
we do the actual if nodding interview
formally if you're on any medication
Norma okay and that do you have any
other medical history of any period of
unconsciousness for any period of time
trouble with anesthesia anything like
Nordahl and any psychiatric history no
okay thank you
oh well I guess one other thing how is
your vision normally so 20/20 or
corrected hmm no it's not twenty Twenty
twenty Twenty twenty ten of my right eye
in about twenty six to my left eye I
wear glasses for a distance and I do
have a pair of reading glasses that I
don't use because to close up okay at
the time of this particular situation
were you wearing glasses no I wasn't
okay I just started wearing better
regularly within the last year okay and
are you to your knowledge
color blind do you have any trouble
separating blues and yellows or reds and
greens no it's recent attested six
months ago I did know it okay
all right any questions for me no okay
Gordon what I'd like to do is read the
consent form out loud
and then ask you to look it over see if
you have any questions back and then try
to address the instructions you have
reads on January 31 1985 at San Antonio
Texas I Gordon Joseph Brennan hereby
agree voluntarily and freely to undergo
hypnosis can be interviewed under
hypnosis in order to assist the Drug
Enforcement Administration DEA with an
inquiry or investigation that DEA is
conducting I understand that change wkt
a special agent of the FBI and it's
myself will be present and assist in the
interview I also understand that a
videotape recording will be made of the
entire interview and that this method of
preservation of the interview may be
used for any lawful purpose connected
with this investigation or any
subsequent action based upon the
investigation dr. Richard B Garver a
mental health professional has explained
the procedures to be used during the
course of this hypnosis session and any
questions I had concerning this
procedure have been answered to my
satisfaction purpose of this interview
under hypnosis is to assist my memory in
recalling events I may have witnessed
associated with an undercover reverse
operation in Miami Lakes Florida on or
about March 11 1981 can I ask you to
look at questions about it
no you feel like you understand it yes I
do dr. Garber can I get you to spend
formatively
do I get to see the tape after it's done
if you want to okay I didn't ask you to
initiate is crossed out so I crossed out
it's necessary
can you tell me what you remember about
this and keeping in mind that our
interest is as it pertains to this
particular event this this operation
okay where which one we're talking right
prior to prior to March 11th I think it
was either the Chancellor probably the
ninth I was down there from Savannah
assisting the agents and operation
grouper I cracked up in a resin
agent-in-charge in Savannah at the time
then we had a another reverse deal go
down at the same location the the
apartment as it was known involving
flashing either 50 pounds or 50 keys of
coke and I got involved in the chain of
custody of the coke it was bothersome to
me that the methods of control they used
for the evidence were not up to my
standards using that as a basis that
when some time before the deal went down
on the 11th I think it was that morning
we had a meeting on how the deal was
going to go and that I said that I was
insistent that we were going to have
some using evidence label for da
evidence labels and secure the money
that was anticipated to be obtained from
the violators seal that in some manner
and that if I special if I was going to
get involved with it and that way I
wouldn't have to be involved in the
chain of custody of the evidence for a
case of it basically the groups in Miami
and that my participation involved
taking a sealed box I could hold it for
a period of time and turn it back over
and still not appear in the official
train of custody because of the my
confidence in the sealing methods that
I'm just uh I would have to be
officially involved in Chain of Custody
so at some time at the meeting in the
morning I insisted that we do use cover
the DEA labels evidence labels and put
it in a box and somehow we got the Xerox
box they then are we all went out to the
undercover area the first thing the
group supervisor surprised me when he
changed a game plan and said you could
handle the outside situation which is
the surveillance and the arrest of the
bad guys after they leave the apartment
with the coke because I figured I was
the only I even thought I was a
supervisor I was only a visitor from out
of town and that I should not have had
that job that was his group in his
operation but I agreed to do it anyway
we got set up on the apartment out in
Miami Lakes the deal was that the
undercover agents were in the apartment
and as we had done in the past I had bad
guys come up to the 7-eleven area call
the house an undercover agent would come
out meet them and lead them into the
area as a protective measure meantime we
had the phone under surveillance at the
7-eleven we determined that they had
received a call
I observed agent he liked him up in the
TransAm meet with the two subjects I
think we're in a Subaru station wagon
and drive towards the house
the surveillance had been planned and we
had set up on the house I set up in a
position that looking down a dead-end or
a cul-de-sac driveway where there's I
think about five apartments on either
side where I could see the sidewalk were
the entrance to the house which is
recessed back off the sidewalk was we
had previously arranged that
if the deal went down and the bad guys
got the coke that the agent Healey would
come out to the car with the bad guy the
visual signal that the deal had gone
down and we would put the arrest plan in
operation
we'd also planned that after securing
the bad guys which was to take place
almost when with inside of the
undercover apartment to keep the guys in
the undercover apartment cool we would
fake hitting the apartment kicking down
the door allegedly and arresting them so
as to make the bad guys think that they
weren't the cops we set up on the
apartment as I said I was sitting I had
a GMC blazer official government vehicle
that I was sitting in with a female
agent from Tampa and a sergeant
deputy sheriff from some rural county
near Panama City Florida scenario was
the bad guys had to come out of this
cul-de-sac and down a narrow driveway
and we had Dade County marked unit at
both ends of it with agents following
them on both ends the coke was not in
the house when the bad guys arrived they
made another phone call and Judge Jeff
Charlotte drove up in his Z car parked
it and took the coke into the house I
took the coke to the door of the house
he turned and sat in his car which was
across the drive from the apartment
eventually Pat Healey and the two bad
guys came out and put something in the
car and since he was with him I know
that then they had the coke I alerted
the other surveillance units and as they
came up and turned down the street
outside of in front of the apartment
Dade County Public Safety unit moved in
from the front
the Subaru stop and they started to back
up and the other Martina came up behind
him
the agents in the car behind the David
county-unit in front came at the car and
by this time I had come over the wall
the retaining wall between the driveway
where I was and where the action was and
the arrest went down the rest and
seizure went down both guys had guns we
seized them the guns and the coke with
the standard confusion it goes down like
one of those deals and then as an
afterthought sort of oh yeah what's hit
the apartment and Jeff got there ahead
of me because he wasn't really involved
in the bust and then I made loud noises
and pulled my shiny automatic out and
says okay let's go hit the apartment and
ran down the short distance to it and
whooping in power and making lots of
noise and looking like a [ __ ] fool
that I went up and beat on the door and
went in inside the agents I remember
that we're in there was Ted weed larry
horn Pat Healy and I think Billy Renton
from Panama City and some way I got the
money and this in the somebody said
there's the box of money that money is
in the box and there were evidence tapes
were on it and somebody also suggested
Harry Hub let's clean up the place
because we expect another bunch of bad
guys in they're going to run a similar
deal again and as I picked up the box
the evidence tapes came off
not completely off they popped off the
bottom and some we're selling our [ __ ]
now I'm in the Chain of Custody the
money I took it back out
I took custody of the money and
initially I thought I had going back to
my blazer over back over the fence but
my memory being refreshed previously
that Jeff and I got in his e car and
drove down to the gas station where some
of the surveillance agents were and
whoever had driven my blazer down there
put the money in the back of the Blazer
and what just stole his female agent and
there was a black agent that accompanied
us back to DEA office I carried the
money upstairs to group one in the group
that I was working with and an agent
from Savannah that worked for me and two
local police officers from the Glenn
County Sheriff our Glenn County Police
Department in Georgia who were with me
part of my entourage counted the money
quickly are counted bundles I don't
recall which and determined that instead
of two and a quarter there was only
about 165 thousand dollars there I
temporarily sealed to put the money back
in the Box temporarily sealed it again I
wrapped it in plastic tape and put my
evidence stickers on it with my name and
everything and stored it until this was
two days later when I took it out and
processed the money counted it again and
again verified to count on it and put it
in DEA evidence envelopes to clear
evidence envelopes and he'll heat sealed
it and turned it in to the cashier
and then I know at the trial the big
stink made about the fact that the money
was not what it was supposed to be I had
since I learned after the trial that the
defense attorney had already given his
defendants polygraph his clients the
defendants polygraph test and they had
passed it or indicated that they had not
taken to money that there was 220
thousand or something like that there
and therefore someone in de I must be
responsible for the loss of it and I
took a polygraph
I guess proved that I didn't have
anything do with it and it's about it
without going into details are you know
questions that's I don't know it's
specific lanoline what that was
important to us and why I've asked you
to go through it like that is that
excuse me quite honestly we don't know
what aspect you played in this and in
service are the roadmap for me I'll be
the person talking to you when you're in
hypnosis it's tourism Road lamp to kind
of get started I think for our purposes
you say there was a meeting that morning
before the bus yeah before the deal went
down there was a meeting I'm pretty sure
it was that morning as opposed to the
day before well we'll use that meeting
as a point that we want to go to okay
and excuse me as you start getting in
touch with it if it's that morning
whether
it'll be academic because you'll
government we don't care if it isn't
proceed hey could you let us know all
right you know what they did when I get
there 84
part of its that the day of the 11th and
then what I'm particularly interested in
or the set of conversation - that's what
happened how you ended up money things
of this nature now basically be the line
that I would like to pursue if at any
time while I'm talking to you
I guess being an investigator you like
to think of yourself as logic or
progressive and I might be in my mind
going from 1 to 2 to 3 to 4 if all of a
sudden you say hey this kids going to
slow for me I want to go to six go to 6
okay I will be starting you out on a
road map but that I feel is
developmental but if anything comes into
your life sure you just say whatever the
hell it is alright and if you don't like
the method of questioning or a lot about
it just say let's try some of those
alright cuz you're engineer turn is my
mind go back into the mean before or to
the March 11th thing but so where we
want to go to the meeting before or the
March 11th
scenario the March 11th morning or more
than one is just just briefly as through
the box
and the discussion the only thing we're
interested in at the meeting really is
saying since the box seems to be the
thing in question any discussion of the
housing of the seal how it's gonna be
treated and instead of what and then
mention on camera she had to be the
meaning that would be the meeting in the
with Group 1 which would be Jeff
Ted Pat and getting the script ready for
their lazy man
no I I'm not yet I'm getting a little
nervous toxic this is the come to quit
well you don't even sit around all day
way more death just like okay
no it's about all okay okay as I as I
mentioned to you before
we're both Jim and I are going to talk
with you and help you be relaxed and and
help you go through this and basically
as you were going through this just now
telling him what what went on probably
as you were thinking about these events
you even had metal pictures that that
formed in your mind as most of us do
when we're recounting
event basically that's what we're going
to be doing except that I'd like you to
start by just closing your eyes and
relaxing just being as comfortable as
you can be and I'm going to be taking
your pulse here if you can just let me
have this so I can have some idea of how
you're doing and if you just take a deep
breath for me now slow and easy and then
let it all out that's fine
another one
this one a nice deep breath and hold it
now
okay Gordon now feel the tension build
and use the tension as a signal just to
release and just let go and just let all
the tension drain away and what I'd like
you to do now is to begin just to drift
back a way that will help you do that is
to start at the number 100 and think
silently to yourself backward by once in
other words think 99 98 97 and continue
to do that and just give me a signal by
moving this finger as you're doing that
okay good that's fine you might time the
count with your breathing every time you
breathe in or out good that's fine
and that just helps you concentrate
consciously and your unconscious mind
can listen to me
and it just happens very naturally very
easily
why are you doing that now I want you
also to just kind of drift back in time
maybe to earlier today yesterday a day
before last week last month it really
doesn't matter what events you touch
upon during this course but the target
is March 11th 1981 at that meeting that
you were just discussing I just want you
to kind of take your time and drift back
to that time and when you when you get
there and I want you to just place
yourself at that meeting so that we can
go forward from there and when you do
that you can stop the counting and you
can just let me know by just raising
this hand completely
another signal that we can use is
there's a part of your brain your
unconscious mind that helps you relax
even more I'm just going to give you a
signal that signal is just pressure on
your right shoulder just like this and
that pressure will be a signal for you
to relax even more become more involved
in in the imagery and when you can get a
picture of you being at that meeting
before it starts or just as it's
starting you you can pick the spot you
know best where to begin
then you signal me and and mr. Kenny and
I will help you get more involved
actually
we're going to be going along for the
ride so to speak and having you sort of
be our eyes and our ears our God
and we'll let you help us really need
you to tell us where we're going next
you want to be there with you and so
there'll be some pictures that are
occurring to us is you explain yours to
us what you're seeing we want then to be
now now to be then and when that time
becomes now you'll want you to go
through that tell us what you're doing
now what you're going to do next and
we'll we'll be attempting to stay with
you and to form pictures in our minds as
well as to what is happening and how you
describe it to us
and I suggest to you that as you learn
this method as you go along that that
you'll be able to use this yourself to
relax and help handle stress